So now, let's talk a little bit about digital image formats.
Basically again, raster image formats, again,
the ones that as I said on a matrix, representation scan, row,
column lies down to rows, well each and every one of those elements is a pixel.
And basically in each and every image is nothing else but
a se, series of colored dots with intensity values.
In the last slide, I kind of started getting into this whole concept of
number of bits for each pixel represents the depth of color.
Well, again, one bit per pixel would just be a two color image where black or
white would be represented.
Four bits would be 16 colors, eight bits would be 256 different colors.
And again if you keep on scaling this,
remember, the equation that we looked at was where n.
n would be 8 for a regular 0 to 255 image.
And just reviewing from last one again, images can be 16, 24 bit,
and 32 bits-per-pixel.
A 24-bit pixel is usually the one that has 8 bits per color.
At the highest levels, the pixels themselves can carry up
to 16 million different types of colors depending on again how,
what bits of pixels which we're ta, trying to use.
Common raster image formats and
this is some things which again you've seen from your cameras a lot,
is basically allowing you to be able to look at images in various formats.
GIF or GIF is one more prominent one.
JPG and PPM, TIF, bpm, BMP, many variety of things exist.
I'm not today discussing the camera RAW format.
We will talk about that later because that's a special format that's coming in.
That actually captures the information directly from the sensor and
stores that into a file for later pre-processing kinds of stuff or
post-processing kinds of stuff.